la madeleine est à proust ce que
l'écrivain et a signé cette commune le
petit marseille a passé plusieurs
semaines de vacances lorsqu'il était
enfant
aujourd'hui elle est devenue un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les fidèles proustien
c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
émouvant de se dire que cet endroit où
il est venu quelques fois a pu avoir une
telle influence sur sa sur sa vie et sur
saône oeuvre sur son écriture
il nous parle aussi de nous nos propres
lieux qui ont éveillé notre notre
sensibilité
je viens de berne en suisse et je viens
ici pour marcel proust
parce que en laissant proust j'ai
compris ma propre histoire voilà le
clocher d'illiez et presque le même qu'à
l'époque ces souvenirs du village et des
paysages proust s'en est servi pour
l'écriture de son oeuvre à la recherche
du temps perdu
cent cinquante ans plus tard c'est à son
tour d'inspirer la commune qui lui
consacre trois jours de festival et même
bien plus que ça en 2021 l'auteur est
plus présent que jamais en 1971 dont il
ya 50 ans pour marquer le 100e
anniversaire de la naissance de proust
on a décidé d'accoler le nom de combret
qui était d'un nom fictif que proust
avait donné à est lié à celui d'il y est
il y est donc devenu décombres est un
phénomène assez rare peut-être unique
même dans l'histoire des villes de
changer de nom comme ça et de se voir
accoler un nom fictif est évidemment un
beau symbole pour la pour la présence de
pouce dans cette danse est cité la
maison de tante léonie musée dédié à
marcel proust bénéficie du soutien de la
fondation du patrimoine
sa restauration commencera à la mi
octobre la mairie voit en cela
l'occasion de faire d'illiers combray
une référence touristique pour les
amoureux de proust
nous avons décidé de profiter je livre
la notoriété de marcel proust encore une
fois notoriété universelle de façon à
faire connaître notre territoire notre
ville de façon à ce que beaucoup de
touristes et l' envie de découvrir cette
ville qui a servi de décor et surtout de
source d'inspiration à l'oeuvre à
l'oeuvre de proust
d'autres festivités autour de marcel
proust devrait avoir lieu ici en 2022
à l'occasion du centenaire de la mort de
l'écrivain